a big problem when we come from a needy  place when we come from a place of  insecurity we start giving people credit  they don't deserve yet I just had the  most amazing date with the most amazing  person oh my God they're incredible  based on what  based on how on what basis what  information could you have possibly got  on one date that enables you to say this  you have been seduced by a kind of charm  Charisma maybe all of that is great I'm  not saying be inherently suspicious I'm  saying you don't know on what basis are  you giving them all of this value  already based on projection and based on  insecurity there's immediate putting  them on a pedestal and putting yourself  down here and when someone smells that  they don't see an equal anymore that's  what I mean when I say challenge I don't  mean artificially constructing games or  Hoops for people to jump through I mean  that the criteria you have for someone  has to be real